I became obsessed with the relationship
between the brain and the mind
after suffering a series of concussions
playing football and rugby in college.
I felt my mind change for years after.
I was studying computers at the time,
and it felt as though
I had damaged my hardware
and that my software
was running differently.
Over the following years,
a close friend suffered
a serious neck injury
and multiple friends
and family members were struggling
with crippling mental health issues.
All around me, people that I loved dearly
were being afflicted by ailments
of the nervous system or the mind.
I was grappling with all of this
while pursuing an MFA in Design
and Technology at Parsons
when a friend and fellow student showed me
an open-source tutorial
on how to build a low-cost
single-channel EEG system
to detect brain activity.
After a couple long nights
of hacking and tinkering,
I saw my brainwaves dancing
across the screen for the very first time.
And that moment changed my life.
In that moment,
I felt as though I had the possibility
to help myself and the people I loved.
And I also realized
that I couldn't do it alone.
I needed help.
So in 2013, in Brooklyn,
with some like-minded friends,
I started OpenBCI, an open-source
neurotechnology company.
In the beginning,
our goal was to build
an inward-pointing telescope
and to share the blueprints with the world
so that anybody with a computer
could begin peering into their own brain.
At first, we were an EEG-only company.
We sold brain sensors
to measure brain activity.
I thought that's what people wanted.
But over time, we discovered people doing
very strange things with our technology.
Some people were connecting
the equipment to the stomach
to measure the neurons in the gut
and study gut-brain connection
and the microbiome.
Others were using the tools to build
new muscle sensors and controllers
for prosthetics and robotics.
And some were designing new devices
and peripheral add-ons
that could be connected to the platform
to measure new types of data
that I had never heard of before.
What we learned from all of this
is that the brain by itself
is actually quite boring.
Turns out brain data alone lacks context.
And what we ultimately
care about is not the brain,
but the mind, consciousness,
human cognition.
When we have things like
EMG sensors to measure muscle activity
or ECG sensors to measure heart activity,
eye trackers
and even environmental sensors
to measure the world around us,
all of this makes the brain data
much more useful.
But the organs around our body,
our sensory receptors,
are actually much easier to collect
data from than the brain,
and also arguably much more important
for determining the things
that we actually care about:
emotions, intentions and the mind overall.
Additionally,
we realized that people
weren't just interested
in reading from the brain and the body.
They were also interested
in modulating the mind
through various types
of sensory stimulation.
Things like light, sound,
haptics and electricity.
It's one thing to record the mind,
it's another to modulate it.
The idea of a combined system
that can both read from
and write to the brain or body
is referred to as a closed-loop system
or bidirectional human interface.
This concept is truly profound,
and it will define the next major
revolution in computing technology.
When you have products that not just
are designed for the average user
but are designed to actually
adapt to their user,
that's something truly special.
When we know what the data
of an emotion or a feeling looks like
and we know how to make
that data go up or down,
then using AI,
we can build constructive
or destructive interference patterns
to either amplify or suppress
those emotions or feelings.
In the very near future,
we will have computers
that we are resonantly
and subconsciously connected to,
enabling empathetic computing
for the very first time.
In 2018,
we put these learnings to work
and began development
of a new tool for cognitive exploration.
Named after my friend Gael,
who passed from ALS in 2016,
we call it Galea.
It’s a multimodal bio-sensing headset,
and it is absolutely packed with sensors.
It can measure the user’s heart,
skin, muscles, eyes and brain,
and it combines that capability
with head-mounted displays
or augmented and virtual reality headsets.
Additionally, we're exploring
the integration
of non-invasive electrical
neural stimulation as a feature.
The Galea software suite
can turn the raw sensor data
into meaningful metrics.
With some of the sensors,
we're able to provide new forms
of real-time interactivity and control.
And with all of the sensors,
we're able to make quantifiable inferences
about high-level states of mind,
things like stress, fatigue,
cognitive workload and focus.
In 2019,
a legendary neurohacker
by the name of Christian Bayerlein
reached out to me.
He was actually one of our very first
Kickstarter backers
when we got started, early on.
Christian was a very smart,
intelligent, happy-go-lucky
and easygoing guy.
And so I worked up the courage
to ask him, "Hey, Christian,
can we connect you to our sensors?"
At which point he said,
"I thought you would never ask."
(Laughter)
So after 20 minutes,
we had him rigged up
to a bunch of electrodes,
and we provided him
with four new inputs to a computer.
Little digital buttons,
that he could control voluntarily.
This essentially doubled his number
of inputs to a computer.
Years later, after many
setbacks due to COVID,
we flew to Germany
to work with Christian in person
to implement the first prototype
of what we're going to be
demoing here today.
Christian then spent months training
with that prototype
and sending his data across the Atlantic
to us in Brooklyn from Germany
and flying a virtual drone in our offices.
The first thing that we did
was scour Christian's body
for residual motor function.
We then connected electrodes
to the four muscles
that he had the most
voluntary control over,
and then we turned those muscles
into digital buttons.
We then applied some smart filtering
and signal processing
to adapt those buttons
into something more like a slider
or a digital potentiometer.
After that,
we turned those four sliders
and mapped them to a new virtual joystick.
Christian then combined that new joystick
with the joystick that he uses
with his lip to control his wheelchair,
and with the two joysticks combined,
Christian finally had control over all
the manual controls of a drone.
I’m going to stop talking about it,
and we’re going to show you.
Christian,
welcome.
(Applause)
At this point,
I'm going to ask everybody
to turn off your Bluetooth
and put your phones in airplane mode
so that you don't get
hit in the face with a drone.
(Laughter)
How are you feeling, Christian?
Christian Bayerlein: Yeah, let's do it.
Conor Russomanno: Awesome.
This is a heads-up display that's showing
all of Christian's biometric data,
as well as some information
about the drone.
On the left here, we can see
Christian's muscle data.
Christian is now going to attempt
to fly the drone.
How are you feeling,
Christian, feeling good?
CB: Yes.
CR: All right. Rock and roll.
Let's take this up for a joyride.
Whenever you're ready.
CB: I'm ready.
(Applause and cheers)
CR: All right, take her up.
And now let's do something
we probably shouldn't do
and fly it over the audience.
(Laughter)
(Cheers and applause)
Alright, actually, let’s do this.
I'm going to ask for people to call out
some commands in the audience.
So how about you?
Straight forward.
(Laughter)
Alright. How about you?
Man: Up!
(Laughter)
CR: Not down.
Oh, he's doing what he wants right now.
Amazing.
(Cheers and applause)
Alright, let’s bring it back.
And what I'm going to do right now
is take control of the controller
so that you guys know
that there isn't someone backstage
flying this drone.
All right, Christian,
you're alright with that?
CB: Yeah.
CR: Unplug.
Forward.
And we're going to land this guy now.
CB: I think I was better than you.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
CR: Amazing.
Now I'm going to unplug it
so it doesn't turn on on its own.
Perfect.
Christian has repurposed dormant muscles
from around his body
for extended and augmented interactivity.
We have turned those muscles
into a generic controller
that in this case
we've mapped into a drone,
but what's really cool is that joystick
can be applied to anything.
Another thing that's really cool
is that even in individuals who are not
living with motor disabilities,
there exist dozens of dormant
muscles around the body
that we can tap into for augmented
and expanded control interactivity.
And lastly,
all the code related
to that virtual joystick,
we're going to open source
so that you can implement it
and improve upon it.
There's three things
that have stood out to me
from working on this project
and many others over the years.
One,
we cannot conflate
the brain with the mind.
In order to understand emotions
and tensions and the mind overall,
we have to measure data
from all over the body,
not just the brain.
Two,
open-source technology access and literacy
is one way that we can combat
the potential ethical challenges we face
in introducing neural
technology to society.
But that's not enough.
We have to do much, much more than that.
It's very important, imperative,
that we set up guardrails
and design the future
that we want to live in.
Three.
It's the courage and resilience
of trailblazers like Christian
who don't get bogged down
by what they can't do,
but instead strive to prove
that the impossible is in fact possible.
(Applause)
And since none of this would have been
possible without you, Christian,
the stage is yours.
CB: Yeah, hi, everybody.
Audience: Hi.
CB: I'm excited to be here today.
I was born with a genetic condition
that affects my mobility
and requires me to have assistance.
Despite my disability,
I'm a very happy and fulfilled person.
What truly holds me back
are not my physical limitations.
It's rather the barriers
in the environment.
I'm a tech nerd and political activist.
I believe that technology
can empower disabled people.
It can help create a better,
more inclusive and accessible world
for everyone.
This demonstration is a perfect example.
We saw what's possible
when cutting edge technology
is combined with human
curiosity and creativity.
So let's build tools that empower people,
applications that break down barriers
and systems that unlock
a world of possibilities.
I think that's an idea worth spreading.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)